citizens of the reject Nation it is time to
watch a movie I have wanted to see forever
that I've never seen and Greg has seen as
a child I did the math I saw it on VHS between
the ages of four to six Craig's never seen
it that does not count you're still seeing
new colors this is RoboCop yeah we're constantly
these movie circles where people are quoting
it and I was telling you I've been wanting
to re-watch it because I never know the references
the the buy that for a dollar I don't know
why RoboCop would say that you said it the
other day and I didn't know it was from RoboCop
until you said it yeah I was like yeah apparently
it's a Robocop I don't know what it means
I hear this movie's actually deeper than cool
machine that kills people and a definitely
four-year-old Greg would never have picked
up on any of that it's just a little Nuance
Greg trying to figure out the meaning of life
so this is gonna be my purpose of my rewatch
today try to recall this MB be like oh okay
this is the deeper meaning and after dread
and the nude red it felt appropriate to dive
into another thing that got a recent remake
that went the other way though yeah where
people didn't love the new one as much but
I'm excited for this one let us know in the
comments what else you want us to watch We're
digging this action movie for Ray we've also
got a bunch of stuff coming up and hit that
subscription Bell that like button hit all
the YouTubey things and as always thank you
to the fine folks at prepper who make this
very video possible they keep us looking good
they leave us looking efficient but you know
how you want us to look not efficient you
head on over to patreon to watch our full
reaction with those moments that the prepper
folks cut out the full experience of our resting
faces the whole shebang over on patreon where
the super sexy rejects live without further
Ado let us RoboCop for the very first time
[Music] oh whoa great opening Dutch angle
Flying Dutch angle a rare touch
oh yeah let's go in the 80s now [Music] crime
news this is media for three minutes and we'll
give you the world I'm Ron Berger that's tick
tock's logo too power failed causing a brief
but harmless period of weightlessness for
the visiting president and his staff we'll
be back interesting opening Santa come down
and talk to one of our qualified surgeons
here at the family Heart Center we feature
the complete jarvik line extended warranties
financing qualifies for health tax credit
and remember We Care this is her comedy this
snarky every policeman knows when he joins
the force that there are certain inherent
risks that come with the territory ask any
cop he'll tell you he can't stand the heat
you better stay out of the kitchen fascinating
identified this man Clarence unofficial Crime
Boss of old Detroit Red from That 70s Show
at Foreman I know that forehead anywhere fight
to save the life of Officer Frank Fredrickson
good luck Frank this has to be like it's comedically
I know it's a satire I had no idea perfect
transferring in from Metro South nice Precinct
yeah pretty good he's got a Killian Murphy
thing about it does the eyes are intense get
your arm and suit up share that line get your
armor and suit up what brings you to this
little Paradise it's me man I think ocp's
moving a lot of new guys up here what a bunch
of morons they're gonna manage this department
and their white asses a lot of butts a lot
of white asses yeah try to get a Meda back
after you've been jammed well I'll tell you
what we should do we should strike
uh-oh and I don't want to hear any more talk
about strike police officers don't strike
can you imagine a cop strike yeah then who's
gonna beat down the strikers the billy clubs
don't worry they've got funding
[Applause] [Music] whoa roundhouse kick standard
cop procedure
women can't punch this Mary Sue what is this
woke [__] from the 80s man this guy's
gonna be your new partner Murphy meet Lewis
Peter Weller is making sure to get all his
brooding stairs in there before they were
moving from him do not blink because you will
not have eyes soon Ed 209 ran into a serious
delays at cost overruns the old man ordered
a backup on Heaven 95th it's a lighter fire
under Jones's ass there's a great editing
to this the pace is wonderful so moved yeah
and the coverage is great sixth position Works
what about this police thing what's the problem
their Union's been pitching ever since we
took over filtered things around I didn't
realize how much of this would be a commentary
on 1980s Corporate America is this is that
what they're doing it feels like at some point
it feels very Frank Miller yeah old Detroit
has a cancer the cancer is crime Detroit's
very different now oh yeah yeah ask Eminem
yeah I think it's time we gave something
I love how self-congratulatory this room is
so proud of everyone and themselves top of
the food chain here thinking about we should
do something for the little people you know
building the city we have gambled in markets
traditionally regarded as non-profit hospitals
prisons space exploration all for profit now
every one of those we believe in efficient
police force is only part of the solution
we need a 24-hour a day police officer oh
they build the RoboCop of course they do why
would the police station the corporate at
the police stationery plug them in plug them
in laughs corporate interest Greg oh they
control the police okay
holy [__] what is this oh actually it
does look slightly familiar to me and they
built it which is cool like that's a thing
that's what Peter Weller's gonna oh my God
whoa It's like claymation stop motion Holy
balls this is awesome
oh sweet it's like Miniatures I think yeah
the enforcement Droid series 209 is a self-sufficient
law enforcement robot 209 is currently programmed
for urban pacification but that is only the
beginning okay
zucchini is going to help us simulate a typical
arrest and disarming procedure this is gonna
go great use your gun in a threatening manner
pointed at Ed 209 yes sir I mean
that's a huge handgun
s to comply oh my goodness
it's roaring 10 seconds
[Applause]
look at them squibs they just killed a guy
look at how I got it it's so violent oh
he's just embarrassed that's why you need
a human in the suit yeah epic I'm very disappointed
I'm sure it's only a glitch your temporary
setback could cost us 50 million dollars in
interest payments alone perhaps you aware
of the RoboCop program developed by myself
at security Concepts as it can go see against
just this sort of thing I love how they're
not concerned at all for the person who died
nope it only that they've just their new Financial
loss structured the police department and
placed Prime candidates according to risk
factor I'm confident that we can go to prototype
within 90 days not expect a full presentation
in 20 minutes and that guy just lost the contract
just moving on so fast ah the cold disregard
for life too bad about Kenny huh life's in
a big city Amen brother that's what happens
you live in a city volunteers
[Music] oh he's a cowboy Yeehaw my son Jimmy
watched this cop show TJ laser and his laser
guy does this every time he takes down a bad
guy and you don't want to disappoint Role
Models can be very important to a boy true
what a weird building of chemistry yeah right
I've got a kid want to meet him it's like
the little exchanges they have [__]
you'll find the [__] money
so he always plays angry people he's very
angry for decades he's been playing angry
people
[Music] is that what Peter Weller's voices
he voices Batman so I think it just lives
there it just wanted a guy who sounded like
a robot you're like a dual wielding he is
a cowboy
[Laughter] [Music]
oh so he was a badass cop before he was a
Robocop who else you're gonna get oh [__]
clearance my legs man I came up he's Expendable
come on Clarence just toss him on the cops
car can you fly Bobby oh he's gonna toss him
on the [__] [Music] don't see about what
red from That 70s Show it's not good for you
[Music] [Applause] [Music] what a fun score
yeah it's very peppy and Lively Central this
is unit 154 we're located at Van by The Old
Mill in sector 3D Now where's that Backup
backup is still unavailable maybe we shouldn't
be a radio it yet so loud like a like a megaphone
we are now here come shoot at us see the millionaire
criminals and the poor criminals all have
no respect for life it's a great equalizer
there's some great camera work in this that
I was not expecting really curious who shot
it because it hasn't stopped moving but it's
not shaky at all it's also edited like a comedy
like there's so many Cuts but they really
work
I got time to pissed [Laughter] mind to find
zip this up
are we watching a movie or uh this is a kind
of pre-cut scene see I actually looked at
it oh she got distracted by his big thing
yep
I like the way they build it he moved I like
how they built the world through the media
yeah it's really interesting Dead or Alive
you're coming with me oh I know that long
I've heard that line too yeah
let us take over from here Emil y
no oh that guy your ass is mine uh yeah
the little boy in me is getting a slight flashback
right now oh is this a moment yeah
where's your partner other one was upstairs
she was sweet this guy's got some Style you
probably don't think I'm a very nice guy
buddy I think you're slime he's scary yeah
he is he's really scary yeah cops don't like
me so I don't like cops
oh [Music]
[__] he's all yours oh
damn they really commit to the Practical effects
here oh Jesus Christ
wow
how's this live I know he's like 1980s [Laughter]
oh man Fun Zone whoa crazy makeup that is
rough okay let's get out of here yeah my brain
just remembered like the rapid fire yeah I
didn't remember the gore yeah that was intense
I just remember the rapid fire that was rough
it's actually a really well done character
setup he's got a son yeah we know that from
a line of exposition they really make you
hate these villains yeah and they're like
maniacal so they're interesting and they're
evil yeah you want him to go and you care
about him with very little screen time they've
established like corporate greed world and
the media as a problem how is he a still alive
there's no way he got shot in the head and
dismembered with shotguns
I mean I guess fitty got shot in the face
but not in the head like right in there they're
right in the brain that's where he controls
his impulses so when he's at RoboCop he won't
have him he's lost like Limbs and stuff gotta
pressure 60 pounds [Music] pressure the place
was right next to the hospital couldn't shave
your nose here Peter Weller come on Peter
let's get some blood drawn type in frosting
six units this pressure's dropping okay yeah
oh there's this kid I was at the shower watches
yeah I really have to tell you blood pressure
I've got 40 pill all right
[Music] whoa crazy shot will she still love
you when you're could you be a robo husband
more Robo than man okay clear [Music]
like really effective let's go okay why is
makeup from older movies so much better they
cared and took time this is where budgets
used to go they were like unsettling too you
know oh yeah now I'm like nauseous that's
that's a lot all right I think that's all
we can do just call it what's the time anyone
notice he has a hole in his head you guys
he got shot I think you shot the attempted
that head he gets from the head I think oh
cool is he gonna come back through yeah POV
has a Robocop
sauce oh that's so clever
[Music]
I thought we'd read on total body prosthesis
now lose the arm okay we're gonna blank his
memory anyway oh he's trying to release forms
and he joined the forest he's legally dead
we can do pretty much what we want oh my God
I love how they just treat him like he's a
product yep he could crush every bone in your
hands all right attach it to his shoulder
good thing you lost an arm yeah we just took
that other one off for funsies
[Laughter] great Exposition character development
through the POV this is fun oh yeah it is
celebration of the success of him too [Music]
[Applause] [Music]
the eeriness of treated him like a child yeah
we get the best of both worlds fastest route
is Reef with modern technology has not good
memory and a lifetime of on the street law
enforcement programming it is my great pleasure
what a well-structured movie RoboCop oh
that's for you go Robo
ah great reveal that was Geniuses that's a
great handle on perspective with her shots
yeah I wonder who shot this I think he's exceptional
what's really impressive about it to me too
is that as much of it as it feels like an
80s movie It Feels So lived in that I don't
feel a distance with it being dated yeah this
is 40 years old almost and it doesn't feel
like that yeah because a lot of times that
datedness can feel like oh I'm kept apart
from it but yeah I feel like more submersed
in it like whether it's dialogue or like Flavor
like they're so good yeah it's about official
ocp business get lost hey this is [__]
I take my order from
ominous sounds of those footsteps this is
so cool
what is this [__]
cops can be replaced oh they wanted to go
on strike too because they were afraid of
artificial intelligence this is what happens
you should have gone on Strike Boston Dynamics
never watched this movie when you're at rest
you will sit in the chair yes I understand
you can check his exact location at all times
with one of these
that sustains these Organics you it's kind
of nauseating what are your Prime directives
serve the public trust protect the innocent
uphold the law
I will commit that to memory huh oh classified
[Music]
ah you can see your robocops [Laughter]
like that they didn't tell him he's just in
there
awesome
what are they gonna do replace us
I love that he's still in there by the way
he flips the gun it's really weird because
it's cool but so [__] up oh yeah it's
haunting and like evil but like awesome go
get him boy got a lot of layers
something tells me the sequels were just like
this robotics made it cool yeah no commentary
yeah we don't want you to think too much
I know this tune uh the strings of
the 80s [Music] he says
shoot Somebody's gotta buy that for a dollar
I don't understand it I love that it's a one-line
cut away like we'll never have got text with
me now move oh my God this is RoboCop superhero
origin story
two
drop the gun you are under arrest
what if you shot his mouth that's what I've
been wondering but it's so small Maybe
oh that's 400 pounds right there he'd be dead
just from then oh yeah head off thank you
for your cooperation good night [Laughter]
[Music]
oh then it comes back around maybe he does
say it because he heard it yeah I doubt it
maybe it is like a superhero it really is
yeah saving the city
let the woman go you are under arrest
[Laughter] that was amazing that was awesome
Madam you have suffered an emotional shock
I will notify a crisis center we will get
you on a couch with betterhelp.com only twenty
dollars a month that was so badass through
the dress thought he was doing one of those
years shoot through the like the movies when
they like shoot them in a spot where they
won't kill them yeah kill the other guy through
the address that was awesome
I only knew shot
this movie is exceptional it is really great
the satire the comedy the action it's all
perfect it like interweaves like in a brilliant
way and the tones all work I think if I was
a kid I would just see it as an action movie
I'm kind of glad I yeah this is great where
the hell do you think you're going keep him
talking okay Miller don't hurt the mayor I'll
give you whatever you want says can RoboCop
ever run yeah I want some fresh coffee and
third I want to recount he wants a recap and
I want a new car and I want the city to pay
for it all what kind of car Miller 35 years
later he would run for president
what Plum Punk speakers what a perfect night
to for a robo cup Crazy Craft
a thermograph
through the wall yes
[Music] RoboCop who is he what is he where
does he come from
this storytelling device of the media is so
impressive genius stay out of trouble
more fighting in the Mexican crisis today
when American troops participated in a joint
raid with Mexican Nationals against Rebel
rocket positions in Acapulco the Iacocca invented
the Mustang so it's great commentary in Corporate
America smart you haven't dismantled your
MX stockpile my border that's it Buster no
more military aid crazy see they do like media
the commentary breaks yeah they like push
their products during like medium warmonger
uh it's crazy there's like a real commentary
on the media that hasn't quite changed today
no it's got worse yeah vice president
Bill I'd love to but uh a date couple models
coming I I'd buy for a dollar ah okay so it
is just the same again
just the thing people say in this city making
a real name for yourself and security concepts
with robocon you try interesting perspective
shop who is the one [__] is the stock
market in front of them while they pee what's
what's that you know he's got this killer
rep but it's a smoke screen space he's lost
his teeth the guys are put well now we know
why would you be so stupid to have this conversation
in public ever
I remember when I was a young executive for
this company I used to call the old man funny
names Iron Butt boner once I even called him
[__] uh-huh is that what you guys do to
me yeah
you can draw like boner over here
bastard creation of yours I had a guaranteed
military sale with Ed 209 who cares if it
worked or not the old man thought it was pretty
important
I love watching movies with two actors I definitely
know from something that I could never place
for I know and I won't tell IMDb you
you were the wrong guy don't mind oh why does
it feel like there's sexual attention there's
so much you better pray that I don't know
lean monster of yours doesn't screw up you
think they'll stick their Robo devices
on this yeah there's got to be a third act
so yeah but I thought it would just be with
the bad guys I feel like Robocat can take
out Red Foreman pretty easy so maybe that
is a fair boy
a human head on a robotic body yeah I was
just looking at the design of the shoulders
how clever that is
oh the PTSD
mind cannot tell the difference oh that's
cool you see a little bit of fragmenting of
like what he sees somehow
goddamn Rebels yesterday great do you think
the peripherals would catch that [__]
pretty bad at their job
end of the lifeline [Music] is he going on
a Revenge Mission no RoboCop nightmares stop
wait a minute
I don't know he just left just left it's you
trying to stop Harry for chat gbt right listening
to us this day will come where's the AI version
of Robocop that's what I want to see who's
the modern filmmaker that's gonna make this
satire commentary because we got a lot of
AI stuff but not in this snarky way I feel
like you could remake RoboCop today with AI
yeah yeah which is right yeah everyone wants
that RoboCop remix but I think Terminator
should be like an AI comment that'd be fun
Murphy it's you
you really don't remember me do you excuse
me I have to go there isn't art to acting
where your mask is on oh yeah such an art
to it what did you say [Music]
no fall safes
yeah this all started with you you activated
it with your nightmares walking down the hallway
now fill it up on number seven I'm a good
shot I could hit you in the eye from here
they cast these villains really well yes that's
a piece of [__] I like to believe they're
they're hiding but believable I bet you think
you're pretty smart huh you think you could
outsmart a bullet he is complying what do
you say we find out huh
drop it hell yeah Dead or Alive you are coming
with me excited every time it's cathartic
I hear that right there
more context foreign
[Music]
whoa that was awesome oh that guy's dead that
that was dead yeah he's real dead
[Music] explosion of the gas station with
an actual stunt guy that was so cool yeah
you could see him standing him amidst the
fire too yeah
wow he's he's gliding through no steps [Laughter]
maybe it's actually got a stabilizer image
wise it could because when we see we don't
it's true area
that could be a violent weapon I enjoyed that
middle finger moment
if those known associates
it's flea
foreign oh my God he's got his whole thing
the whole gang the whole gangs Revenge mission
he's got really pretty lips it does they cast
well
uh oh
damn that's a mind [__] right there
yeah the movie's also a tragedy it's so sad
our lead is dead great transition to memory
yeah
can you do that Dad what happened in there
all right
this is so sad I really have to tell you something
oh my God she was saying something sweet wasn't
you yeah oh there's a little smirk at the
end of that oh they cut it right before the
smoker like oh was she divorced him or some
[__] yeah man
where is Clarence He's the bad guy from blade
I think he's in one of the blades
[Applause] everyone's just like they hate
this guy get rid of him how you doing oh how
do they know each other you do it okay oh
dude
dude please please don't kill me all right
hello buddy boy dick Jones here ah hired a
hit you don't feel so lucky now do you whatever
he's paid you I'll double it right now five
goes on it's an old story The Fight For Love
and Glory hubbab Corporate America working
with this bad guy [Music] [Applause] [Music]
that's too bad you seemed like such a nice
guy I got the muscle you shove enough of this
Factory so far up your stupid whop ass Frankie
blow this [__] his head off can't can't
[Music] come on Sal the tigers are playing
two nights I never miss a game he is great
he is so good he is really captivating
I want to buy some cocaine I'm low on batteries
do you have cocaine
the most 80s thing ever is a dust of cocaine
and RoboCop walking through
oh my shoes targeting targeting
it takes a breath too I like the over the
shoulder yeah yeah [Music] Boogie you are
under arrest you have the right to remain
silent you [Music] oh yeah wait a minute I'm
protected man I've got protection you have
the right to an attorney oh [__] his own
rules right now JP's the senior president
anything you say may be used against you
God is all going to record yeah I might need
it later oh yeah there we go
[Music] it's crazy how much character they
gave RoboCop yeah book him what's the charge
say it say it he's a cop killer Oh I thought
I was gonna say murdering Murphy yeah I thought
he was going to list all that the lawyers
will have you out in 24 hours just don't say
anything else she really screwed up he did
say your name I just got access to the camera
though right there is a tracker on him oh
but that homeboy is gonna have his big mother
effort yeah that's gonna be a fight there's
got to be someone that can fight robocopics
there's no one that could Stakes you are under
arrest Chuck eating and abetting a known felon
sounds like I'm in a lot of trouble [Laughter]
oh product violation oh crazy is that the
classifier yeah okay insurance policy called
direct before
senior officer both CP results in shutdown
what oh so now he's in control Corporate America
no accountability
okay
I
had to kill Bob Moore because he made a mistake
time to erase that mistake
no oh that is scary so monstrous [Music]
oh [__] oh damn he's actually damaged
this does that like hero and villain being
the same entity but in a really good way
oh his eyes thank you
[Applause] cool awesome
oh you gotta be [__] me Rockets robo-roll
[Music]
a very good aim on this thing the super close-ups
really work for the emotion
oh it's actually like disconcerting to see
RoboCop all front and running I'm like okay
oh the eye is so cool oh it was not designed
for steps his big enemy stairs my one weakness
how'd they get him up here push him down the
stairs oh become its friend robocon earn its
Trust it's okay they're there I don't know
they treated like it's an animal it's a little
baby oh come on foreign
Peter Weller we have orders to destroy it
oh [__]
see the capture the criminals the exact same
thing it it's not an it
wow surprisingly great at raising Stakes too
yeah jeez like all the odds are against him
right now I feel so bad for him so bad they
say you do a Superman movie like he's you
know impenetrable but we're finding those
where's your lady cop friend [Music] she know
to be right there is that all just coincidence
maybe she saw him rolling [Laughter]
modeling walks out in a suit I I am so surprised
by how truly fantastic not gonna lie people
were like this movie's deeper than people
giving credit and I was still like I was like
yeah maybe sure whatever Robo guy yeah no
this is like a four and a half Stars
that thing is still alive I don't know what
you're talking about the police officer arrested
you the one you spilled your guts to see how
they did yeah allergy nasal is pretty uh Clarinex
yeah he recorded every word you said his memory
is admissible as evidence you involved me
you're gonna have to kill me admissible good
word we're gonna need some major Firepower
got access to military weaponry we practically
are the military oh this movie's got some
things to say same privatized military and
privatized police are a problem Greg corporate
interest May hinge on those beliefs in a system
that works yep cool Robo guy but this Robo
guy yeah did you bring the gun the precinct
was deserted half the forest didn't show up
for work today my God he just sounding like
a dude now yeah they're humanizing them your
gun you asked for this I brought you some
food
oh thank you I'm not hungry oh this is a sweet
boy I love you RoboCop you got my heart oh
he's unscrewing his head oh we're gonna see
a maskless what's underneath
where's the sun in my they moved but oh my
God it that's what they meant by the freaking
Guardians Guy what's his name yeah I never
got that reference [Music]
you're very much Society it is
a gray bar Hotel not bad they let me keep
the shirts
they let me out of jail for free damn they've
all got let out what do you got through Clarence
whoa whoa watch this demonstration
[Applause]
is this the same warehouse where Murphy was
born I was gonna say I love the synchronicity
of her being with him again for the end against
them but in the same place yeah is it the
same spot
oh it's kind of creepy with his mask yeah
human face move that way I still care about
you I'm just uncomfortable [Applause]
yeah dude what are you doing don't tell them
where you are
those fierceness in his eyes [Music]
if they aim on that kind of Cannon could not
be easy the last thing I forget to dissociate
with this movie is that it's surprisingly
moving yeah it's like actually like it gets
you in the field surprisingly okay
anyway a little little skip there right into
the toxic waste
no he'll be back as a super villain in the
sequel he's the joker now ace chemicals oh
my God what's happening
I thought he was just gonna be dead oh it's
melting oh man the 80s were different what
is happening he's a Toxic Avenger well that
was so gross they melted him that was so disturbing
wow I thought it was just gonna roll out yeah
oh man I thought everybody treats him like
he's the worst one of them all oh 100. [Music]
oh the other side of his face is even worse
what is happening this guy
he came up in his Golem oh yeah you liquefied
him I don't know why this movie hates himself
much this keeps picking on him they just liquefied
him
oh [__] that's what I was worried about
God damn it oh wow characters really get shot
this one got blown up
oh you walk on water my resurrected man that's
right [Music]
oh
[Music] yeah a little too late I mean yeah
but at least he's dead
oh [__] oh
Terminator to take some oh my god oh can you
get him oh oh right of the jugular
you got way too
I'm a mess they'll fix you everything it makes
everything
dick Jones is wanted for murder these are
serious charges what is your evidence yeah
plug it in I had to kill Bob Morton because
he made a mistake now it's time to erase that
mistake
I want a chopper now oh but protect they could
it could override with a directive hey fire
him can it dick
[Music] [Applause]
damn good call right because immediately directives
I don't know what you meant by that yeah his
arms were alone
very poorly saved it for the end nice shooting
son what's your name Murphy again oh hell
yeah damn talk about a movie that lives up
that was so good that age is incredibly that
is one shot I didn't like it it's in the last
30 seconds wow that was so good it wow I'm
actually like really Blown Away by it I I
really went in going that I was kind of going
in thinking that maybe maybe I'd be a little
bored until they finally became
I don't care about anybody
like free conceived Notions for some reason
like ah baby it's gonna be whatever yeah and
then maybe it's like over hyped and and but
no that was that was a genuinely like phenomenal
experience genius attire genius comedy in
and out of universe like the way it addressed
us and the action in the DP was like insanely
good I love the editing I love the way it
was filmed I loved like the writing was fantastic
that was so good I I'm kind of Blown Away
by it because it does so much it's got the
social commentary of the political commentary
commentary that's relevant to even today that
I wasn't expecting yeah uh uh the the the
fear of replacing uh that I mean obviously
all the stuff about like Corporate America
and whatnot and and Military and workers rights
but but then it also like just had menacing
villains and a really solid character in Robocop
and for some reason they'll tip it did the
t09 sorry he's like a legend Phil tip it's
like one of the best visual effects artists
my my knowledge on that is not the most wide
but yeah that was probably my my big my biggest
surprise was how much I cared about RoboCop
because kind of like you could say Superman
or kind of even like when we watch dread like
I love dread easily one that's probably one
of my favorite reaction videos we've ever
done ever on this channel um but one of my
things about it was I I never really fear
for dreads right at no point did I think and
I love the stakes escalating here yeah to
the point where I was like how are they gonna
make the villains worth fighting how are they
going to make me worry about RoboCop but then
by the end I was like are they just gonna
rebuild him in part two like I thought he
might actually die yeah and that's impressive
for a movie to make me worry about or lead
to that level yeah I was I I really felt for
Murphy the character the the way how you know
you'll have like the superhero identity but
then the person underneath who they really
are sure with their first name right and I
I didn't expect to connect so much to Murphy
because in all honest it's like I like I like
Peter Weller it was like reasonably Charming
enough sure before he became RoboCop so the
last thing I expected was so like it more
whispered to evolve as a character with me
foreign
all right I thought we got our movie um and
I thought like the main voice character of
the movie would be like what the movie's talking
about it would be the real it would be the
real character I didn't expect so much to
care about RoboCop himself I thought he'd
just be like an aesthetically pleasing guy
and it was really neat but I I felt for him
and and I thought it was tragic and and and
uh yeah when he was getting like shot when
like the bad guys are coming down and the
cops coming down I'm like man it's so messed
up he's already had such a terrible life but
like yeah they're terrible for this guy Catherine
Hardwick did the TJ laser stuff I don't know
any of these people Catherine Hardwick's uh
director of hurt locker and like oh James
Cameron yeah that's what I know whereas that's
your only identity to me that's like a huge
director she started on Point Break that's
huge did she do the first Twilight anyway
uh was it her I don't think that's correct
I don't know I know the first I know the director
of the first file I did Lords of Dogtown but
I can't place if that's the same director
anyway she was like uh the laser crew the
one who did 13. yeah I'm gonna look it up
I'm gonna do the Cardinals I gotta know uh
but yeah I was really impressed with like
everything they were able to do with Nuance
but also the commentary on so many different
things never clouded the other like it had
so many different tones but they never crossed
over and made it like oh that's invalidated
that's invalidated yeah and some of the visuals
were like oh when he gets the mirroring of
the the criminal shooting him to death to
the cop shooting him to death being a mirroring
of the commentary on the whole movie and using
some of the visual Aesthetics and everything
was genius oh great point they literally cut
to a side shot of more cops shooting him with
the same uh angle as they did with the five
bad guy and I thought that was genius there's
there's a lot of re-watch ability sure that
I that I wasn't expecting to pick up on either
I oh yeah there's yeah definitely little I
think the only thing I really remember was
like a flash of him getting shot up like when
you were a kid yeah yeah yeah because that's
pretty funny as a child what have I seen the
arm getting blown the hand getting blown off
I didn't remember that yeah it was so rough
that was crazy but I don't know I saw a lot
of violence when I was younger yeah all players
together it all blurs together after a while
uh the movie was also very huh I don't think
we've ever even learned his first name that's
and he was so compelling who Murphy that was
his first name it wasn't wasn't Murphy I was
assumed it was officer Murphy because Murphy
was on his badge wouldn't that be your last
name like don't you go by like you'd be Alba
I assumed that it wasn't like Murphy Brown
no because it said it said Murphy on his uh
on his name uh on his jacket yeah so I think
we never even learned his first name oh interesting
that's just an interesting way to like that's
compelling me we don't even know a full uh
I mean I thought the I thought the movie also
too was what I loved about this kind of dystopian
future and as we said a lot during the reaction
so I'm trying not to just repeat everything
we said but what I love about this kind of
dystopian future is that it felt very tangible
as well you know I I think from what I recall
about the reboot of Robocop and and recall
and like the total recall for the trailers
I've seen of that is that it's just so hyper
CGI and so futuristic you know it's like everything
tries to become like Blade Runner all the
sudden or something like that yeah Fifth Element
I would say you know and it keeps his hands
and so here this is uh this this felt like
very this felt plausible like this felt believable
in in a lot of ways and I think the the way
they did the shots too like there's a lot
of these great tracking shots here with like
superb editing as well and it's it's like
consistently menacing but it's got that like
real Twisted kind of sense of humor yeah you
know yeah I was really impressed with some
of the shots the fact that POV worked in this
so well POV rarely works for me I'm usually
like that's a gimmicky shot but they use POV
in such an event of way when not only is he
dying and then the reboot that narratively
is great but then they were able to reincorporate
that rebooted image to give us a POV of him
to give us characterization he's only showing
this much of his face because you're living
with his view yeah which is genius the propaganda
commentary oh my God the commercials were
genius how they made the because it's all
focuses on Detroit but the media gives you
a sense of the world I also can't believe
it's like it's set in Detroit which is the
American cart City and there were so many
commentaries on like original car consumerism
like Lee Iacocca is the guy that invented
the Mustang which was huge for the city of
Detroit Lee Iacocca school is a commentarian
like consumerism to a level they've got the
car that's got 8.3 miles per gallon in a city
that's known for building gas guzzling cars
when the gas guzzling cars went away Detroit
crumbled like all of that layers oh [__]
I didn't know all that yeah so like that's
a genius commentary on just the American consumerism
with corporate America with destroying the
planet consumerism that's a big part of the
film that is a huge part of the film but yeah
the car stuff was genius because if you don't
know you're not distracted but if you do know
you're like Lee Iacocca Drop Like that's crazy
yeah this movie is deeper than he is crazy
good it's actually like really deep but it's
but it also is a very just entertaining film
yeah at no point was I not like enjoying the
giddiness of a good action movie even while
I was going like that's so smart like some
movies are heavy-handed enough that it leaves
the action behind because you're thinking
and that's fine for that tone but at no point
did I leave the action movie while also thinking
because you have to be like because I could
also see how this thing spawned into a action
franchise with a TV there's like a live action
TV series that I've never seen and then there's
the animated TV series which cannot be nuanced
it is in video games you know like I could
totally see how RoboCop became that yeah based
off of just what a Robocop is because it's
so cool because you see it's so cool and all
um but the but this first movie I kind of
don't even want to watch this I'm really scared
I I don't want to because I feel like it would
just like upset me it'll like Sully this it's
the opposite of dread where like the new one's
amazing and it makes the first one better
I'm afraid this will be like diminishing returns
I think that's exactly how it would go I'd
be surprised if it I don't know how you could
possibly this is like a per it's almost perfect
I give this four and a half Stars which I
rarely do like this is a very high this might
be my favorite thing we've watched yeah I
think my only thing is like I like the the
lady I like she's the reason I like her uh
but they're and I I care more about them when
they were connected post to him taking off
the map yeah that those parts I did care about
more but there was occasionally these things
with the with this sweeter more like tender
dramatic scenes that's a little weird because
they played odd instead of like natural like
yeah it didn't feel natural um and so other
than like those little little things there's
yeah there's not too much very tiny there's
very intermittent things that I would forget
about that I'm like oh yeah yeah whatever
that's not that guy has really long arms they
like gave him prosthetic arms to make the
the depth of field look like he was falling
faster but instead he just had really long
arcs oh the makeup was phenomenal God crazy
makeup like what they were able to do with
that like now High evolutionary look but like
what they were able to do with making it look
like he was plastered to metal and like how
he was in the suit is so genius like I really
felt like that was a Robocop did they pull
that off in some ways it looks more impressive
than high evolutionary yeah 87 in the face
right yeah I mean still impressive but God
damn this movie was really cool yeah it was
like it was like constantly unsettling but
but always captivating yeah um yeah I loved
it I really loved it I didn't expect to walk
away I thought this was I thought it was uh
I thought it might have been a little overhyped
the 80s is also like the height of like raw
raw spend I didn't expect things to be like
it's dangerous to live this way like this
was a movie that we made now that like certain
news channels would complain about like this
is a movie that could exist today with the
same commentary that would be like oh won't
go broke and instead it was in the height
of that era I watched Terminator one quite
a lot growing up yeah um mainly because Terminator
2 is like arguably my favorite movie of all
time I like this more uh but I'm not I don't
I don't love Terminator one as much as I maybe
I should I wish I felt a lot of it is just
to like get determinated I don't I'm not as
in love with it I I like this morning Terminator
one this is like one of my favorite action
figures by quite a bit I actually I I like
this more than terminal one like the the action
is not maybe the best sure like but that's
that was the thing is that's not my main takeaway
with this film because the action is relatively
simple walks around but it's all the emotional
surrounding context around the action that
makes it so interesting and and and and worthwhile
and the cinematography makes up for the action
for me exactly yeah like maybe no point maybe
the choreography is the greatest yeah because
you've got a guy that only has so many hinges
like what can you do like the fact that he
even did some cool over the shoulders I was
like that's impressive whereas I would be
like even Terminator Terminator two came out
a few uh several years after this but Terminator
2's action sequences I'm still like oh those
are phenomenal yeah some of the best of all
time yeah whereas here I wouldn't say like
the action figures are here are phenomenal
but the the context around them are so good
but every but every scene felt so important
I think James Cameron's wife uh ex-wife is
Catherine Bigelow and Catherine Hardwick is
the one that directed Twilight and Lords of
Dogtown I mixed it because I'm like there's
no way the person that directed Twilight also
directed hurt longer like doesn't feel right
I think Catherine Bigelow Catherine Hardwick
are dude for people
yeah I think James Cameron's wife is Catherine
Bigelow uh I was just so bothered by that
I'm like there's no way she directed all of
those things uh but yeah James Cameron's obviously
got an action aesthetic that influenced so
much but this influenced way more than I realized
we said you know there were some lines of
dialogue but also I do think you're right
there's some Terminator moments here in this
first oh yeah but this stabbing yeah I was
like that's like straight up what happens
in Terminator 2. some of those frames are
the same yeah this was so impressive this
might be my favorite thing we've reacted to
ever and I loved dread like this and Dread
are my top two yeah I just love I love the
mood uh throughout because the move was was
changing but ah that was I'm kind of I'm kind
of I'm taking it back a little bit
yeah that was that that is a wildly impressive
film sometimes when you do these reactions
it's hard because like you know you're on
camera and you're aware that like you're watching
something and sharing it and that's harder
to ruminate on like sometimes we film so I'm
like okay my day's on like and I leave but
this is something I'm like oh I just watched
a thing that I know I'm gonna think about
I want to watch it again I like found myself
going if I set it during it like if this plays
in the theaters I want to go see it 100 this
is playing it like The Arrow or some like
you know old movie theater I'd love that it's
so well crafted and the music's [__] amazing
too and it's it's cathartic like yeah this
was this was a surprising I I feel like I
shouldn't be surprised yeah everyone hyped
it and it's even better yeah yeah I think
that's a I think it was just so hyped that
most of the time people do that [__] it's
it's it can't be delivered and I'm like it's
a [__] 80s movie about a machine about
a robocopy yeah also like an 80s movie it's
really hard to live up to people's expectations
of their age when they watched it like we
weren't 17 watching this yeah we were I mean
I wasn't even alive yet but we weren't yet
like in that era so I was really worried about
people that love it just having Nostalgia
because their parents might have showed them
that's what I thought it was a Nostalgia you
know what I mean there was no Nostalgia tied
to this except for I've seen the figures of
Robo but I was like but I bet it's a little
boring that's what I thought I was never born
not once not once I was bored I thought it
was really interesting the entire time and
and it does have more in its my mind and you
can see like I can see I was the same guy
made Starship Troopers I can't wait to read
essays on this like I'm excited to like read
about it I don't feel that often anymore where
I'm like I can't wait to learn the things
I missed before we go you want to just see
what like the other robocops are rated yeah
I was thinking about like how did they do
really because this was amazing because what
if like RoboCop 2's all right what if like
three is a sneaky hit like we just don't know
about it because two sucked like there's like
one more good one I heard one of them if I'm
not mistaken a fun fact just popped into my
head I heard one of them is PG-13 whoa which
is like a Telltale that's a crime we need
to how many robocops are there is that the
show you were talking about why is there like
20 robocops I don't know what these other
robocops are Resurrection I don't know the
names Paige Fletcher does not yeah I have
no idea oh 49 for the new one God damn oh
damn oh my God nine percent on three nine
oh Robert a Peter Weller didn't even return
for well after you get a 28 dude ripped horns
hit one 28. only 40 people watched it from
Rotten Tomatoes oh damn even the audience
score is terrible dude it's got a 40 reviews
for real critics 50 000 audience ratings 36
dude that is rough oh I I don't know if I'm
101 I don't think I don't I don't think we
need it uh oh God 50 000. I mean regardless
the asinine Circle should be placed under
arrest maybe we skip two and go right to three
yeah because I was like a really fun time
okay Frank Miller co-wrote oh dude do you
want to just watch three like because I don't
want to be sullied but if it's this bad maybe
if we skip you know what I mean did Frank
Frank Miller co-wrote two and three and they're
terrible oh because it's so it's the first
one so Frank Miller he didn't he didn't co-write
this one well this feels like what influenced
a lot of his Comics so it's interesting that
wow dude nine we've never done a nine percent
movie damn the Remake has better reviews but
then either of the sequels the Remake has
a better audience score and reviews uh God
damn that is crazy but I mean still nothing
still not great what about it Samuel Jackson
Ooh Jackie Earl Haley oh I love Abby Cornish
maybe we should just skip to the remake I
mean three in the dream it could be funny
but it's just a remake it looks like it's
such a reason look at how bad that image is
that image is just my suit is so cheesy yeah
look at how much again red visors he's just
wearing a Power Ranger suit he's just literally
like I think rope but like this came out like
what 10 years ago yeah I I think it was one
of the first trailer reactions I ever heard
and I remember being so hyped for it no at
10 years ago Greg plays to the kind of audience
member that oh that's so funny like oh you
got the sweet slick version of Robocop guys
it's so edgy he's corporate branded he's got
the C on his chest and it's like this the
fact that it exists is kind of the what RoboCop
stands against the fact that there's three
of them and shows Corporate America made a
show an animated show and a sequel yeah that's
I mean I'm down man that was uh this first
one's Immaculate though I cannot believe how
good that was I don't know if I could sit
through those other two that just sounds awful
that does sound rough all right I don't know
what these other robocars
the animated films are like what are they
well it's like I don't know live action what
is this action sci-fi the rated R hour and
a half MGM television what Robocop and cable
find refuge in the temple of a techno-religious
order they're just making stuff up all right
well that exists what did they do to report
you ruined my favorite movie I love this so
much stop making them she ruined up Jesus
do you think we should do the 10 year ago
I'm giving you a fun comparison yeah you think
we should we do two and three or just which
I think just skip two yes okay go right to
this I I can't do that too much yeah I love
the okay yeah and that way we don't have an
association because it's so much newer it
won't feel I mean it won't feel connected
yeah all right you let us know yeah dear audience
let us know if we should watch 2014's RoboCop
with the understanding it will not be as good
uh we know what we're getting into should
we watch 2014 Joel kenneman Robocop let us
know in the comments below if you enjoyed
this journey as much as we did please do hit
that like hit that notification Bell and hit
that comment on what you want us to watch
next I'm loving these action movies it has
been an absolute blast so please let us know
what you want us to dive into and we'll be
back with some more goodness soon thank you
for being here thank you for watching much
love reject Nation we'll see you soon foreign